you ever hear someone say I lost all my
retirement when the stock market went
down you ever hear somebody say that let
me help you with this that was a lie
I know in their emotions they felt like
they lost all their retirement but if
your 401k were invested in good growth
stock mutual funds the worst time in the
history
INRI in the last 50 years the last since
the Great Depression the worst we've
ever had was 2008 the stock market
dropped from the Dow Jones Industrial is
about 13,000 dropped about 6500
basically in half and so that means if
you had $100,000 in retirement it became
worth 50,000 did you lose all your
retirement no did he go in half yeah
does that suck yes but you didn't lose
it
unless you cashed it out it just went
down oh by the way did it come back up
to 13,000 did you get all your money
back
yeah is it above 13,000 now yeah try
over 20,000 yeah that's your Dow Jones
Industrial Average so look at those
percentages it went down in half and now
it's almost fourfold what it was at the
bottom so you're 50 and if you had
50,000 at the bottom you're a hundred
thousand because worth 50 should be
worth 200 now on stock market averages
so you didn't lose any money at all on
your retirement unless you put it in at
the highest point and took it out at the
lowest point which makes you like the
world's worst possible investor ever
I mean you bought it exactly the wrong
time and you sold at exactly the wrong
time and then you did lose half of your
money but you didn't lose all your
retirement money lost half of it
and the only reason you lost it was no
one gets hurt on a roller coaster except
those that jump off ride it to the end
ride it out I don't know
is this market unusually high right now
yeah
is it overdue to come back down yeah
yeah and you know if Trump and North
Korea decided to bump bellies and have
trouble and decided to just fight and
spit at each other which they're doing
you know are we gonna could we see a
correction could we see a downturn yeah
yeah you could good is that gonna be the
in the world nope
it'll be the end of your retirement nope
am i taking any money out because of
that
no am i putting money in every month yep
have for 30 years well I got millions of
dollars in there never stop putting
money in just always put some money in
when times are bad I put money in times
are good put money in why because I know
and common sense tells you that over the
scope of the next 10 or 15 or 20 years
are those companies we named off a while
ago gonna be worth more or less on
average on average the best and
brightest companies in America 20 years
from today 15 years from today will be
worth more than they are today it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to
figure that out now will some of them go
out of business yeah yeah but the best
and brightest ones which is who the
mutual fund companies picked to invest
in sometimes they miss it but I'm by and
large they buy the winners more than
they buy the losers are you going to be
okay over the long haul yep so when you
hear about floods and hurricanes and
North Korea means you're watching too
much fox news too much CNN it's been all
your time watching negative stuff and
then you start doing your investing
based on the world coming to an end and
the world will always have trouble and
the world will always have good things
always always be investing always be
investing every time we talk to these
millionaires in the millionaire theme
hour you know what they tell me we
started putting money in our 401 K or 25
or 35 and we never stopped we never
stopped oh and now having that worth of
2.2 million or 4.6 million or 1.7
million or whatever
is when they call in they just didn't
stop investing just kept investing kept
investing kept investing kept investing
it's what I do that's what you should do
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]